bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
sur public sénat cet après midi les
sénateurs poursuivent l'examen du projet
de loi portant création d emplois
d'avenir
il entre dans le vif du sujet avec la
discussion de l'article 1er qui prévoit
donc la création de ces emplois aidés
avec la création d'une disposition
particulière dans le code du travail
ces emplois aidés je vous le rappelle
vont bénéficier à 150 mille jeunes d'ici
trois ans jeunes de 16 à 25 ans peu ou
pas qualifiés et venant de zones
défavorisées alors ce texte s'il n'ya
pas le consensus de la part de la droite
pourrait malgré tout bénéficier de
quelques voix comme celle de l'ancien
premier ministre jean pierre raffarin ou
encore celle de philippe marini le
président de la commission des finances
qui a fait savoir qu'il voterait ce
texte le vote
en tous les cas elle devrait intervenir
ce soir tout de suite donc la direction
l'hémicycle bonne chance à tous la
séance est reprise
je suis saisi d'un rappel au règlement
le monsieur jacques mézard
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues par un
rappel au règlement
nous entendons dénoncer avec force les
attaques lamentable contre les élus et
le sénat en particulier qui ont été
faites par le député rené dosière
lequel a énoncé des contre-vérités
flagrantes reprise sans aucune
vérification par les médias je cite
quelques extraits si on enlevait la
réserve parlementaire au sénat ça
enlèverait une sorte de suspicion avec
la réserve on peut penser qu'on cherche
des voix qu'on va en acheter
monsieur dosière ne sait même pas
renseigné sur la situation réelle et
méconnaît les réformes mises en place
ces dernières années et en particulier
la dernière année les propos de monsieur
dosière s'inscrit en fait dans une
démarche globale visant à stigmatiser
les élus en corrélation avec la question
du cumul des mandats
la suppression de la réserve
parlementaire ne me poserait aucun
problème je l'exprimé dans mon
département en étant transparent sur son
montant et son attribution
mais est-ce différent des subventions
accordées aux communes par les exécutifs
départementaux régionaux
faut-il aussi supprimer la réserve
ministérielle mes chers collègues quand
le sénat est attaqué par un député avec
des propos fallacieux
il est sain que le sénat réagissent le
président du sénat l'a fait lors des
journées parlementaires du parti
socialiste nous devons le faire en
séance publique
et je pouvais espérer que le groupe dont
fait partie monsieur dosière aurait pu
regretter ses propos mais c'est un autre
débat
lorsqu'on est lorsqu'on est au cinquième
mandat de député et qu'on découvre les
pseudos aux errements de ses collègues
élus lorsque l'on fut président du
conseil régional maire de laon
conseiller général il ya deux pages de
titres divers
je pense qu'il est quand même délicat de
donner des leçons aux autres et nous
savons tous que les excès d'intolérance
sont la marque de fabrique des nouveaux
convertis qui sont d'ailleurs toujours
dangereux bien sûr le fonctionnement de
nos assemblées doit être encore
améliorée bien sûr la transparence est
toujours nécessaire
mais ce n'est pas et ce n'est jamais en
favorisant le développement d'un anti
parlementarisme que l'on fait vivre la
démocratie c'est au contraire le plus
sûr moyen de la fragiliser
bien monsieur mézard donc je vous donne
acte de votre rappel au règlement
l'ordre du jour appelle la suite de la
discussion du projet de loi adopté par
l'assemblée nationale après engagement
de la procédure accélérée portant
création d emplois d'avenir dans la
discussion des articles
nous sommes parvenus à l'amendement ce
numéro 5 rectifié au sein de l'article
1er parole est à madame pro cassia merci
monsieur le président et bien cet
amendement vise à bien préciser
clairement dans le texte de loi que les
emplois l'avenir puisque c'est une forme
très particulière de contrat de travail
et de ses idées et bien contrôlée par
les inspecteurs du travail dans les
mêmes conditions que pour tous les
autres salariés
je vous remercie jure collègues
la parole d'un monsieur genro pour la
merci monsieur le président je voudrais
rassurer madame procas ya bien entendu
cet amendement est satisfait puisque par
définition
l'inspection du travail a vocation à
contrôler et à vérifier l'ensemble de
l'application du code du travail y
compris sur les emplois d'avenir
je vous demande donc de retirer votre
abonnement ou nous mettrons un avis
défavorable
je vous remercie monsieur le rapporteur
quel est l'avis du gouvernement monsieur
lui même avis donc ne pas user les
retirer mais j'apprécie d'avoir des
explications en séance et de pouvoir les
voir au jo
merci bien l'amendement est retirée nous
suit sésime maintenant de l'amendement
numéro 70 qui est présentée par monsieur
dassault
je présente ce nul chaque règle cet
amendement introduit une vérification de
l'apport de l'opportunité de signer un
contrat d'avenir pour l'apprentissage et
enfin nous aurions qu'un probable
lorsqu'une situation sont plus adaptées
vers l'apprentissage aussi concernés et
les candidats et est impératif
très vite les effets de pure opportunité
que cette forme de contrat soit en
adéquation avec le premier professionnel
du jeune en difficulté par ehpad
difficile le contrat d'apprentissage
sont ainsi prioritaire sur les contrats
d'avenir et c'est le point important
l'apprentissage est le meilleur moyen
d'obtenir que les jeunes apprennent un
métier et ne se retrouve pas en
situation de manque de formation
professionnelle et par la suite au
chômage son travail mais pour soi les
jeunes ont besoin de travailler en
alternance dans une entreprise et c'est
la seule façon pour eux d'obtenir une
véritable formation professionnelle mais
entreprises sont réticentes
car soir prend du temps ils doivent
payer un maître d'apprentissage pour
faciliter ces formations en alternance
fondamentale il serait utile que les
contrats d'avenir puisse être utilisé à
cela
ce contrat sera signé aki chef
d'entreprise qui recevront en
compensation une chambre 75 50 %
évidemment à décider promu nice du
montant le croire d'avenir pour
activités non marchandes
mais je pense il était utile de ces
fichiers que contrat d'avenir peuvent
aussi servir à des contrats en
alternance pour lesquelles il manque
vraiment des apprentis il manque des
entreprises pour recevoir les apprentis
merci je vous remercie
chers collègues quel est votre avis
monsieur le rapporteur bien l'amendement
présenté par monsieur dassault est en
réalité satisfait puisque l'emploi
d'avenir je le rappelle sera prescrit
par le service public de l'emploi ou par
la mission locale
en fonctions précisément du projet
professionnel du jeune et il s'adressera
en toute priorité à des jeunes en
situation de décrochage scolaire pour
lesquels précisément une entrée en
apprentissage immédiatement n'est pas
envisageable
autrement dit vous pouvez avoir la
garantie
aux termes de ce texte que la
prescription sera fait en fonction très
précisément du profil du jeune je vous
demande donc puisque cet amendement est
satisfait de le retirer à défaut nous
donneront un avis défavorable
quel est votre ami monsieur le ministre
monsieur le président je voudrais redire
moi même ce qui a très bien dit le
rapporteur
mais monsieur dassault jeudi déjà dans
la discussion générale
notre objectif c'est pas de prendre en
emplois d'avenir des jeunes qui
pourraient trouver une autre solution
est tout particulièrement une solution
de formation ou d'alternance ou
d'apprentissage donc à l'évidence le
comité de pilotage devra j'en donnerai
l'instruction vérifier préalablement que
toutes les autres solutions ont bien été
utilisés
elles auront toutes été utilisé en tous
les cas on aura fait la liste et on aura
regarder précisément si une autre
solution ne peut pas être proposés aux
jeunes en question
on commence pas par l'emploi d'avenir on
termine la liste si je puis dire des
possibilités offertes aux jeunes parlent
emplois d'avenir puisque c'est justement
fait pour ceux qui n'ont aucune
possibilité ni en termes d'emploi ni en
terme de formation donc je souhaitais
vous le dire clairement et précisément
pour que vous puissiez prendre votre
décision sur votre abonnement en toute
connaissance de cause oui monsieur
dassault le problème n'est pas seulement
de convaincre lapentti le futur apprenti
mais de convaincre une entreprise de le
prendre parce que le problème est là
c'est le problème des des facilités
le choix par une entreprise adaptée un
apprenti pass culture des jeunes qui
sont prêts à l'apprentissage ne trouvent
pas d'entreprise
donc ce que l'on sait c'est de préciser
alors dans votre décision se munissent
que les chefs d'entreprises qui
utilisent un apprenti en droit à
utiliser le contrat la lumière sinon ils
ne prendront pas même si vous êtes
favorable pour l'apprenti pour qu'ils
aillent dans une entreprise il faut que
je retrouve et accepte et c'est ça le
problème aujourd'hui que j cl peu
d'entreprises va pas assez d'entreprises
en france accepte ce qui fait que les
jeunes qui veulent être apprenti ne
trouve pas d'apprentissage ne trouvent
pas d'entreprise et ne peuvent pas
exercer leur l'information dans le
moment on a maintenant est plutôt
destiné aux entreprises pour qu'elles
sachent qu'ils peuvent s'y lie à
possibilité utilisée un affronter avec
la possibilité d'avoir un contrât
l'avenir c'est pas tout à fait pareil
alors je laisse mon amendement puis vous
jugerez s'il est bon ou pas mais si vous
pouvez dire si vous disiez que vous
serez d'accord pour que les entreprises
utilisent ce convenir pour payer un
apprenti qui suit évidemment toutes les
consignes et toutes les précisions et
que je voulais apporter ce serait bien
mais il faudrait que l'entreprise soit
aussi
favorisé par ce contrat pour prendre la
porte et qu'il ya un monsieur jeannerot
souhaite intervenir
je voudrais vraiment rassurer pleinement
notre collègue monsieur dassault comment
concrètement les choses vont-elles se
passait le jeune se présente à pôle
emploi ou plus souvent la mission locale
il vient parce que il a entendu parler
que un emplois d'avenir étaient
susceptibles de lui être proposé il y
aura une vérification faite par l'agent
de la mission locale
il pourra advenir dans un certain nombre
de cas qu au lieu de lui proposer un
emploi d'avenir il lui soit proposé un
contrat en alternance ou un contrat
d'apprentissage parce que précisément ce
sont ces le profil du jeune qui sera
examiné ses motivations son niveau bref
ce travail d'évaluation sera fait par le
prescripteur
donc il n'ya pas d'à priori pour qu'il
soit automatiquement orientés en emplois
d'avenir
l'ensemble des possibilités sera
examinée à cette occasion donc vous
pouvez être pleinement rassuré bien dans
ces conditions monsieur dassault quelle
est la risée d'entreprise ça a prévenu
qu'elle pourra utiliser les covered
bonds voile alors fait d'accord merci
donc l'amendement est retiré je vous
remercie monsieur dassault nous passons
maintenant à l'amendement en numéro 106
présenté par le gouvernement et le
président c'est un moment vraiment
purement rédactionnelle qui permet
d'ordonner de manière plus visible et
plus clair l'ensemble des éléments
d'information que qui devront être
fournis à l'appui d'une demande de
d'emploi d'avenir l avis de la
commission c'est un avis favorable
puisque c'est un amendement de
clarification rédactionnelle qui a pour
objet vous l'avez compris a réaffirmé à
repréciser les obligations de
l'employeur bien
alors qu'ils s'opposent à cet amendement
présenté par le gouvernement
il n'y a pas d'abstention qui est pur il
ya un amendement en numéro 106 est
adopté je vous remercie
nous passons maintenant à trois
amendements en discussion commune
le premier l'amendement numéro 47 et
présentée par monsieur des césars et
monsieur vos leaders alors par cet
amendement est d'abord une situation
complexe puisque en matière de formation
et sa aborde le problème de l'école je
ne sais pas si on pourrait parler d'une
école à deux vitesses mais autant peut
dire que l'école parfois elle permet de
s'élever et sortir de son milieu social
on a en permettant à chacune et à chacun
d'avoir carrière qui permet de sortir de
milieu social d'origine défavorisée par
ailleurs et en même temps l'école peut
conduire à l'échec scolaire et l'échec
scolaire et congelés d'hier ça peut être
la quadruples plein première peine on
n'a pas de diplôme et donc on a de la
difficulté que que l'on peut avoir est
ce qu'on est jeunes de s'insérer sur le
marché du travail deuxième peine ça nous
poursuit toute la vie c'est à dire les
personnes qui partent avec un une
qualification très basse et bien c'est
un peu ça reste un plancher toute sa vie
par rapport à une carrière sociale
troisième peine
et bien c'est un sentiment d'échec pour
le jeune pendant toute sa scolarité une
dévalorisation et 4e peine ils
s'embêtent il s'ennuie et ya même un
dégoût pour le système scolaire et donc
monsieur repentin hier nous a bien
expliqué que par rapport à ces jeunes en
situation d'échec il fallait pas vouloir
tout de suite leur coller une formation
et il fallait au contraire partir de ce
qu'ils étaient de la reconnaissance
qu'ils allaient acquérir par leur
travail de deux de leurs compétences et
qu'il fallait justement être souple
quant à la formation que nous allions
leur proposait donc ça par rapport à ces
jeunes en situation d'échec
effectivement un suivi personnalisé a
été affirmé par le ministre de la
formation professionnelle
mais dans le même temps pour un certain
nombre de jeunes
il est important que leurs acquis
pendant ces trois ans soit reconnue et
validée et alors que pour les emplois
jeunes il ya un certain nombre
d'exemples qui montrent que ça n'a pas
toujours été le cas car l'employeur se
refusait à les inscrire une formation il
faut leur assurer une formation donc par
cet amendement tout en étant conscient
que c'est une chose pas facile puisqu'il
faut tenir compte d'un suivi
personnalisé tout en poussant
l'employeur a aidé à une formation à
acquérir une formation qualifiante et
bien cet amendement souhaitait que tous
les jeunes puissent bénéficier d'une
formation qualifiante et demander à
l'employeur la prise en charge de la
formation bien je vous remercie monsieur
dsa
quel est l'avis de la commission se
gêneront alors pardon ils sont encore en
discussion comme une joue prie de
m'excuser l'amendement numéro 61 et
présenté par madame basket
merci monsieur le président la vocation
des contrats aidés et donc des emplois
d'avenir dont nous débattons aujourd'hui
est de favoriser l'insertion
professionnelle et sociale du pub de
public particulier ciblé dont on estime
qu'ils nécessitent une mobilisation
particulière des acteurs publics etat
sécurité sociale régions et
collectivités territoriales
s'il ne fait aucun doute que la
possibilité pour un gène de connaître
une première expérience professionnelle
peut servir de tremplin vers l'emploi
dans l'immense majorité des cas cela ne
suffira pas le faible niveau de
formation initiale des jeunes concernés
dans ce projet de loi doit être
pleinement mesurés et l'aspect formation
des emplois d'avenir doit être aussi
important que l'exercice professionnel
lui même
c'est pourquoi nous ne pouvons nous
satisfaire de la rédaction actuelle du
projet de loi qui prévoit que la
qualification auquel le jeune peut
prétendre puisse
substitué par une simple reconnaissance
de compétences il ya pourtant entre
qualifications et compétences des
différences réelles
en effet il est difficile de se prévoir
prévaloir de compétences en dehors de
l'entreprise dans laquelle elles ont été
acquises contrairement aux
qualifications qui elles permettent aux
salariés d'être rattachées une catégorie
professionnelle préalablement établie
est défini dans une grille de
classification d'une convention
collective
or on sait que tous les jeux ne seront
pas recruter définitivement de la
structure les ayant accueillis
nous proposons donc que la loi ne pose
pas les deux notions et que les
employeurs prévoient à la fois le niveau
de qualification espérée par les actions
de formation mise en oeuvre ainsi que
les compétences que le bénéficiaire de
l'emploi d'avenir pourrait acquérir à
défaut le risque est grand que les
employeurs privilégient pour des raisons
évidentes d'organisation et de kout la
non réalisation des actions prévues
devant entraîner le remboursement de
l'aide
l'acquisition de compétences au
détriment des compétences des
qualifications l'acquisition d'un niveau
de qualification que nous souhaitons
supérieurs aux niveaux précédemment
acquis constitue un bagage utile aux
jeunes ainsi recruter leur permettant
enfin de s'inscrire dans un parcours
d'emploi plus sécurisé le bénéficiaire
d'un emplois d'avenir pourra ainsi
disposer pour l'avenir d'une expérience
professionnelle du permettant de
prétendre à l'issue de ce contrat
un emploi plus qualifiés et donc plus
rémunérateurs bien merci chers collègues
l'amendement 113 et présenté par le
gouvernement
une ce président cet amendement a pour
objet de d'aller dans le sens des deux
amendements qui viennent d'être
présentés c'est bien par monsieur
désessard que par le groupe communiste
mais il faut juste bien comprendre
on a tous en tête les jeunes concernés
ce sont des jeunes qui sont très très
loin la formation très loin en échec
total
nous voulons tous et c'est un des
objectifs peut-être l'objectif principal
des emplois d'avenir qu'ils puissent
acquérir une qualification ou acquérir
les réflexes qui permettent de rentrer
dans la qualification mais nous avons
des jeunes qui sont très éloignées et
donc la préoccupation du gouvernement
c'est d'une part d'affirmer clairement
qu' on doit offrir ce parcours à chacun
des jeunes mais sans décrire ce parcours
comme arrivant à des niveaux qui serait
est inatteignable par le jeune en
question sinon on aboutit à une
situation inverse
l'employeur ne prendra que le jeune dont
il sentira qu'il peut atteindre cette
qualification il laissera de côté celui
justement vers lequel nous nous tournons
donc il faut totalement affirmé la
volonté de qualification du processus
mais ne pas mettre le niveau trop élevé
parce que si vous mettez la barre trop
élevé les gamins ils essaient y passe
pas dessous il reste à la porte
donc voilà vraiment la préoccupation qui
est la nôtre c'est le risque de votre
amendement qui part d'une idée que je
partage totalement cette volonté qu'un
jeune lorsqu'il sort s'ils sortaient
mais même s'il reste dans la même
entreprise est un bagage et 1b gages
comme on dit dans le jargon
transférables qui est une valeur qui
n'est pas une valeur seulement dans
l'entreprise mais qui est une valeur
alors dans l'entreprise dans
l'association où dans la collectivité
mais qui est une valeur reconnue à
l'extérieur donc c'est pour tenir compte
de ces préoccupations dans l' équilibre
que je viens de décrire
absolument il faut une formation mais
attention à pas vouloir une formation
absolue sinon ils vont rester dehors que
je peux donner qu'un avis je le fais
déjà cet instant là monsieur le
président défavorable aux deux
amendements et pour répondre à vos
préoccupations
le gouvernement propose cet amendement
qui de notre point de vue maintient le
bon équilibre entre la volonté de
qualification et la volonté de ne pas
fixer des niveaux trop élevés qui ne
pourrait pas être atteint par les jeunes
en question
bien quel est l'avis de la commission
monsieur leur nombre est bien fort
simplement mes chers collègues la
commission partage complètement l'avis
du gouvernement tel qu'il vient de vous
être exposés et je voudrais reprendre
chacun des amendements proposés très
rapidement l'amendement 47
je rappelle présenté par notre collègue
décès sarthe en exiger que les jeunes en
emplois d'avenir acquièrent des
compétences et des qualifications et
n'ont pas ou vous renforcer l'exigence
de formation paramétré par une
qualification
il s'agit là d'une restriction pour les
motifs que vient d'exposer monsieur le
ministre et que je ne vais pas reprendre
qui risque de mettre à mal le projet
même d'emploi d'avenir
par ailleurs votre amendement exige que
l'employeur prennent obligatoirement en
charge tous les frais liés à la
formation ce qui évidemment est excessif
puisque je vous rappelle là aussi que le
gouvernement il l'a exprimé souhaite
remobiliser l'ensemble du dispositif les
opca le fpspp le cnfpt
nous l'avons nous avons vu les
amendements et les régions de manière à
mobiliser l'ensemble des moyens au
profit des jeunes
donc je demanderai à mon collègue de
retirer cet amendement
sinon la vie sera défavorable
l'amendement 61 et proche du 47 là aussi
je ne vais pas reprendre l'ensemble de
l'argumentation qui vient d'être
développé appelle les mêmes commentaires
néanmoins il me semble et ça fera la
transition avec l'amendement suivant
l'amendement 113 présenté par le
gouvernement que le gouvernement nous
propose une voie de compromis qui est
équilibré qui met le curseur au bon
endroit et je vous propose
je demande aux porteurs de l'amendement
47 ha
pardon 61 à madame pasquet de retirer
l'amendement
faute de quoi pour les raisons que je
viens d'indiquer la vie sera défavorable
il me semble j'en arrive à l'amendement
113 que ce qui nous est proposé par le
gouvernement constitue une bonne voie de
compromis plaçant le curseur au bon
endroit permettant tout à la fois de
garantir un accès à une formation à des
compétences et je reprend les termes de
l'amendement à un niveau de
qualification supérieur à celui qui
était le sien lorsqu'il est entré dans
l'emploi d'avenir cet amendement me
paraît constituer un bon compromis un
bon chemin pour garantir la bonne fin de
l'emploi d'avenir je vous propose un
avis favorable et je vous propose
d'adopter cet amendement bien monsieur
lessard et madame parce qu avez-vous été
convaincu monsieur des césars président
j'ai été très sensible aux propos du
rapporteur et j'ai bien aimé la façon
dont le gouvernement a traité cette
question donc je retire mon amendement 1
madame parce que
s'il vous plaît parce que c'est à vous
merci monsieur le président alors sur la
question de la formation
nous avons déposé cet amendement mais
nous étions déjà en accord avec
l'amendement déposé par nos collègues de
l'assemblée nationale qui eux aller bien
plus loin que nous est demandé une
formation qualifiante de 400 heures par
an sur pendant trois ans pour nous là
maintenant 61 sait déjà c'est déjà un
compromis
nous ne voulons pas opposer les
compétences et les qualifications
nous pensons que les deux sont utiles
pour l'avenir de ces jeunes quand ils
seront sortis de l'entreprise
accueillante et ce 6e
cet argument est confortée par le l'avis
du cse concernant ce sujet qui lui aussi
préconise qui ait de véritables
formations qualifiantes et reconnu je
cite puisque je laisse ou lisieux est
reconnue par un diplôme ou une
certification inscrits au rncp
voilà donc nous comprenons le pas que
fait le gouvernement
/ / / la question de la formation espace
qui nous concerne nous estimons qu'une
ça ne ce n'est pas ce n'est pas
suffisant nous nous maintenons notre
d'autres amendements et nous nous
abstiendrons sur l'amendement du
gouvernement
vous avez bien compris chers collègues
je vais donc mettre par conséquent au
voir cet amendement numéro 61 pour
lequel la commission et le gouvernement
ont émis un avis défavorable qui est
pour
qui s'abstient qui est contre il n'est
pas adopté il n'est pas adoptée jeu mais
maintenant on voit l'amendement du
gouvernement numéro 113 qui est pour cet
amendement qui et contre qui s'abstient
il est adopté
j'en viens maintenant à l'amendement 33
rectifié qui est présentée par monsieur
marseille ce président est monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues cet
amendement précise que si la formation
suivie par le bénéficiaire d'un emplois
d'avenir se déroulent en dehors du temps
de travail elle ouvre droit à une
allocation de formation dans les
conditions du droit individuel à la
formation
l'obligation de formation est partie
intégrante du contrat aidé cela suppose
tout naturellement que les heures de
formation soit en partie rénumérés au
même titre que dans le cadre du dif
montant de l'allocation formation ainsi
que les frais de formation correspondant
aux droits ouverts au titre du dif sont
donc imputable sur la participation à la
formation professionnelle continue
l'employeur peut faire une demande de
prise en charge financière du dif à
l'opc à l'organisme paritaire collecteur
agréé de branche ou à l'opc à
interprofessionnelle dont il relève
c'est donc une mesure qui va dans le bon
sens puisque on s'adresse à un public
est en difficulté qui a des moyens
faibles et l'employeur lui va recevoir
les moyens de pouvoir faire bénéficier
aux contrats au titulaire du contrat les
moyens dont il aura besoin pour suivre
sa formation
merci je remercie japonaise quel est
votre avis et mathieu jeannerot
l'amendement porté par monsieur
marseille propose donc vous l'avez
compris de verser une allocation jeunes
qui suit une action de formation en
dehors du temps de travail selon les
mêmes modalités que celles prévues pour
le dif alors l'idée
nous paraît intéressante mais nous nous
interrogeons sur ce que pourraient être
ses modalités d'application
et je souhaiterais sur ce point
sollicité l'avis du gouvernement
monsieur le ministre au gouvernement
cet amendement est totalement justifié
il est même tellement justifier aussi
les messieurs marseille je voie publique
à celle à cet amendement est tellement
justifier qu'il n'a pas d'objet je vais
vous expliquer pourquoi il ya des textes
qui existent qui sont applicables à
toutes les modalités de formation dans
le cadre professionnel dans le cadre
d'une entreprise d'une association ou
d'une collectivité locale
ce texte qui sont compris en particulier
dans le code du travail vous faisiez
allusion ou dif au droit individuel à la
formation sont de droit applicables aux
dispositions qui concernent les emplois
d'avenir de droit
celle que vous citez comme beaucoup
d'autres donc ou bien on reprend toutes
les dispositions du code de travail pour
les remettre une deuxième fois parce que
je vous rappelle que nous sommes en
train de modifier le code du travail
donc on peut faire une photocopie d'un
autre article puis de le remettre la
médaille ce cas il faut faire tout le
code du travail ou bien nous considérons
ce qui est le vrai le droit je vous le
dis ici que les dispositions du code de
travail dans le domaine de la formation
sont applicables de plein droit aux
emplois d'avenir donc il est inutile de
vouloir en quelque sorte grossir si je
puis dire le dispositif emplois d'avenir
de dispositions qui lui sont par
ailleurs directement applicables
j'espère m'être fait bien longtemps mais
sinon on va avoir un code du travail
étrangement fait qui va comprendre deux
fois la même chose à deux endroits
différents
alors que à un endroit applicable à
l'ensemble c'est quand même plus clair
est me semble-t-il de meilleure
législation
monsieur marseille je remercie le
ministre de nous apporter cet éclairage
parce qu'il n'était pas évident dans le
texte est ce qui est telle qu'on pouvait
lire donc fort de ces explications je
retiens d'un moment nous nous présente
est peut-être le suivant
le 34 rectifier alors cet amendement
précise que ces actions de formation
peut faire l'objet d'une prise en charge
par le fonds paritaire de sécurisation
des parcours professionnels
le fonds paritaire de sécurisation des
parcours professionnels a été créée par
la loi du 24 novembre 2009 relative à
l'orientation et à la formation
professionnelle tout au long de la vie
il a pour but d'assurer la qualification
des demandeurs d'emploi par des actions
adaptées avec une attention particulière
pour les personnes les plus éloignées de
l'emploi en aidant dans le bon contexte
à ce titre les fondus fssp peuvent
légitimement être mobilisés pour le
financement des actions de formations
prévues dans le cadre des emplois
d'avenir c'est donc là l'objet de notre
amendement merci je vous remercie chers
collègues qu'elle avait de la commission
bien le gouvernement nous l'a assuré il
a déjà engagé des discussions avec le
fonds paritaire de sécurisation des
parcours professionnels pour déterminer
dans quelles conditions ce fonds
pourrait intervenir pour financer les
actions de formations prévues dans le
cadre des emplois d'avenir
la précision proposées par cet
amendement ne me semble pas
juridiquement indispensable mais en même
temps elle ne me paraît pas poser des
problèmes particuliers c'est pourquoi
mon avis est un avis de sagesse bien je
vous remercie
quel est l'avis du gouvernement ancien
ministre ses loisirs comme tout
amendement qui dit peuvent en
l'occurrence c'est peu pourrait
considérer que juridiquement tout ça n'a
pas grande importance puisque c'est
simplement une possibilité qui est
ouverte
mais là aussi j'essaye de voir ce que ça
veut dire en terme de bonnes
négociations d'écriture d'un texte qui
est un sens juridique qui soit le plus
précis possible donc votre préoccupation
monsieur marseille c'est de savoir si le
fpspp pourra participer à des actions de
formation des emplois d'avenir en
question la réponse est évidemment oui
ça fait d'ailleurs partie de ses
fonctions de ses objectifs
ce pourquoi il a été institué je le dis
d'autant plus oui que nous sommes en
train et c'est monsieur repentin dont je
vous prie de bien vouloir excuser
l'absence en cet instant car il est à
l'assemblée nationale
le cadre de la réponse aux questions du
gouvernement monsieur repentent à est
actuellement en cours de discussion
comme vient de le dire très bien le
rapporteur pour la période 2013 2015 ou
une nouvelle convention cadre devra être
signé avec les partenaires sociaux
et dans le cas de cette convention-cadre
la possibilité que vous souhaitez ouvrir
sera bien entendu affirmé mais nous
irons au delà de la possibilité la
réalité de la participation sera affirmé
dans cette convention card voilà
pourquoi cet amendement qui au fond ne
mange pas de pain puisqu'il ne crée une
possibilité me paraît du point de vue
strictement rédactionnelle inutile mais
sur le fond des choses vous êtes
normalement assurées par les propos qui
sont les miens de la participation du
fpspp sg-marseille aux estimé satisfait
tout et je remercie monsieur le ministre
de ses explications mais depuis hier
soir on a beaucoup d'explications sur le
contenu de ce texte qui à l'évidence
pense donc de de précision donc
s'agissant de ce point particulier je
maintiens mon amendement donc il est
maintenant bien donc je mets au voir cet
amendement 34 rectifier pour lequel et
la commission et le gouvernement ont
émis un avis défavorable non un avis de
sagesse sagesse pour la commission est
défavorable pour le gouvernement bien
qui est pour
montella
qui est contre
alors un bon eh bien nous allons faire
assis lever bien alors qu'ils aient pour
cet amendement vous vous lever 3 4 5 6 7
8 9 10 ans 11 12 13 14 casse enfin 83 23
vous pouvez vous rasseoir qui contre
vous lever
car il n'ya plus de doute et il n'est
pas adopté
nous passons maintenant à l'amendement
62 qui est présenté par madame pasquet
madame parce que l'amendement 62 n'ont
donc c'est monsieur watrin qu'ils prient
sur le président chers collègues
l'exposé des motifs du projet de loi
prévoit que le montant de l'aide de
l'état dont le niveau sera fixé
réglementairement un point important
sera dans le cas général de 75 % de la
rémunération brute au niveau du smic
comme beaucoup ici je crois comme le
gouvernement dans ses intentions nous
faisons preuve l'égard des employeurs
potentiels d'une véritable exigence
quant à leurs obligations à l'égard de
l'état qui débloque les aides
financières nécessaires et donc aussi et
je crois en premier lieu à l'égard des
jeunes concernés par ces futurs contrats
l'assemblée nationale a d'ailleurs
renforcé cette exigence en prévoyant que
le non-respect des obligations
contractuelles qui figure sur la demande
des nz entraîne automatiquement le
remboursement intégral de celle ci pour
autant il nous semble que des
dispositions supplémentaires devraient
être mises en oeuvre pour que et c'est
le point fondamental les emplois
d'avenir ne soit pas comme on l'a vu
avec d'autres formes de contrats aidés
des contrats précaires supplémentaire
est largement subventionnée moi j'ai
dans mon département beaucoup de jeunes
qui aspirent en décrochage qui aspirent
à des contrats mais qui ne volent pas de
contrat de énième contrat précaire en
l'état actuel du droit laissait hui cae
les celui-ci ses yeux qui sont les deux
formes que peuvent ressentir les emplois
d'avenir dans le cadre qui nous est
proposé dans cet état de droit les aides
publiques sont modulés en fonction de la
catégorie et du secteur d'activité de
l'employeur en fonction des difficultés
d'accès à l'emploi antérieurement
rencontré par le salarié ainsi que des
conditions économiques locales
pour autant il semblerait et c'est notre
souci que ces aides ne soient pas
moduler en fonction d'éléments très
important pour les jeunes je dis qu'ils
souhaitent un contrat durable à savoir
la durée de travail hebdomadaire donc la
rémunération qu'ils percevront ou encore
qu'elle ne soit pas moduler en fonction
de l'insertion durable dans l'emploi
c'est à dire de la nature même du
contrat qui leur sera proposé un cdd ou
un cdi
il ne nous sommes donc pas illégitime
que les employeurs qui privilégie la
conclusion de contrats à durée
indéterminée des cdi contrats sécurisant
pour le jeune qui lui permet l'accès
l'autonomie soit plus soutenue et plus
encouragés que ce qui pourrait proposer
des comptes rend durée déterminée ou ce
qui profiterait la clause de revoyure
pour réduire la durée initialement
prévue
c'est le sens de cet amendement que nous
vous proposons de que cet amendement que
soit par décret instaurer un tel
mécanisme de modulation je vous remercie
chaque collègue quel est l'avis de la
commission sur cet amendement
merci monsieur le président je vais
devoir opposer malheureusement un
monsieur watrin un avis défavorable je
voudrais rappeler que la règle dans les
emplois d'avenir c'est le contrat à
durée indéterminée et une modulation de
l'aide en fonction du contrat ou de la
durée puisque les dispositions ont prévu
que dans des cas effectivement
particulier le temps de travail puisse
être au minimum d'un an
modulée en fonction du contrat ou de la
durée du temps de travail aurait pour
effet à de subventionner plus fortement
finalement les employeurs les plus
solides financièrement ce saut c'est à
dire ceux qui sont les plus à même
d'offrir des contrats longs à temps
plein donc il ya là une contradiction
que nous ne pouvons évidemment soutenir
ce qui explique l'avis défavorable
je vous remercie ancien ministre et
l'avis du gouvernement ce président je
vais redire là aussi l'objectif c'est le
contrat à durée indéterminée je vais
vous le dire encore autrement
un comité de pilotage qui se voit faire
des propositions de la part d'employeurs
potentiels et qui aura des cdi et des
cdd choisira le cdi pour un emplois
d'avenir
ils prirent priorité au cdi parce que
nous souhaitons que le contrat à durée
indéterminée soit le contrat de droit si
je puis dire pour les emplois d'avenir
donc au fond je pourrais dire très bien
vous avez des dispositifs qui vont
encore renforcer cette obligation
mais attention deux choses d'abord
n'oubliez pas ayez toujours ça en fait
parce que beaucoup des dispositifs que
vous proposez sont inspirés de ceux que
l'on pourrait souhaiter dans le domaine
des entreprises privées nous ne sommes
pas là en l'occurrence on a eu le débat
hier dans quelque chose qui est ouvert à
l'ensemble du domaine marchand privé
d'ailleurs c'est un élément de désaccord
avec une partie de cet hémicycle
justement parce que nous pensons qu'il
faut pouvoir accueillir ces jeunes les
encadrer les accompagner donc attention
à ne pas à chaque fois qu'on dit
employeurs pensent et celui qui va
chercher à abuser ça existe d'ailleurs
j'ai proposé aux partenaires sociaux
qu'il réfléchit sur cette question là
dans le cas de la négociation sur la
sécurisation de l'emploi
nous sommes avec des gens qui des
employeurs qui vont devoir faire des
efforts pour accueillir ces jeunes qui
vont devoir faire des efforts pour les
accompagner pour leur donner une
formation
donc je dis ça parce que faire très
attention hein on parle pas de
l'employeur comme on en parlerait d'une
manière générale on parle de cela non
pas aussi des collectivités locales
d'ailleurs dans une collectivité locale
je sais pas comment vous faites pour
accueillir le jeune en contrat à durée
indéterminée ça n'est pas possible
le contrat sera forcément de trois ans
même si j'en suis persuadé les
collectivités territoriales inscriront
dans la durée le parcours de ce jeune
par exemple pour remplacer tel ou tel
salarié qui partiraient à la retraite
aux employés qu'ils partiraient à la
retraite donc voilà je veux vous rendre
attentifs à cela parce que sinon la
conséquence est celle que vient de
décrire le rapporteur tous ceux qui
peuvent se permettre de s'inscrire dans
la durée
cela ils vont avoir l'aide la plus
élevée au fond les plus riches auront
l'aide la plus élevée et puis toutes les
petites associations ou les petites
collectivités locales qui peuvent pas
s'inscrire dans la durée parce que à ce
stade là au moment où elles font la
proposition l ont pas la visibilité est
à dire les plus pauvres
celle là elles auront l'aide la plus
faible il ya là quelque chose qui me
paraît très contradictoires y compris
par rapport aux objectifs qui peuvent
être les vôtres
voilà la raison pour laquelle pour ces
raisons là je ne peux pas donner un avis
favorable à cet amendement est au
contraire s'il était maintenu
je pourrais donner qu'un avis
défavorable qu'en pensez vous monsieur
votre 1
je maintiens cet amendement parce que je
crois qu'on est au coeur du débat de
fond sur ces emplois d'avenir
est ce qu'il s'agit de faire beaucoup
d'emplois d'avenir d'arriver à tout prix
et je dirai quelle que soit
quelquefois les situations assez 150000
euros
cent cinquante mille emplois qui sont
visés voilà est-ce qu' il faut y arriver
coûte que coûte je dirais moi nous nous
sommes plus on check le débat hier à on
a on est revenu au tuc
on sait ce que c'est les la succession
de contrats aidés de contrats précaires
que vivent les jeunes qui ne débouchent
pas sur un emploi pérenne
on en a fait la liste hier on voudrait
que ces contrats soient un petit peu
innovant et que on incite les structures
employeuse eh bien à faire les efforts
nécessaires d'insertion de formation de
pérennisation plus que du chiffre plus
que voilà et donc on est au coeur du
débat et nous pensons que ces contrats
d'emploi d'avenir ne doive est d'abord
des tremplin vers l'emploi et nous
maintenons cette cet amendement parce
que il nous semble que il faut
sensibiliser les structures employeuse à
cette situation et donc les aider
financièrement en fonction des
engagements qu'elles pourront être
amenés à réfléchir en signant déjà le la
demande l'aide auprès de l'état et en
faisant en sorte qu' il ya une mecque
maximum de pérennisation donc nous
maintenant cet amendement bien non
progresseurs pour explication de vote
explications de vote et interrogations
on parle du celi
mais dans tout l'est s'est dit il ya
aussi des périodes d'essai or les
périodes d'essai elles peuvent être de
trois mois de six mois quelquefois même
de 1 an
j'aimerais savoir si vous avez prévu
quelque chose puisque monsieur le
ministre vous nous dites que vous voulez
avant tout privilégier des cdi
quand même temps ces jeunes sont
tellement éloignés de l'emploi
comme vous nous l'avez dit et répété que
proposer un cdi à des jeunes qui n'ont
jamais travaillé qui ne savent rien
faire et s'engager pour trois ans ça va
être difficile donc il y aura sans doute
des période d'emploi j'aimerais
tout simplement et il n'y a pas de piège
derrière je n'ai pas pensé à vous poser
la question en commission parce que ça
ne m'était pas venu à l'esprit pour vous
répondiez franchement est ce que vous
allez faire quelque chose par décret
puisque beaucoup de choses se font par
décret ou comment gérez vous ces
périodes d'essai ce ministre répond à
cette question mais on en revient à un
certain nombre d'amendements qui ont été
parfois des positions au sujet le droit
commun s'applique donc ne réalisons pas
tout le code du travail il est très
épais il est très long elle a beaucoup
de dispositions le droit commun
s'applique en l'occurrence s'agissant
d'un contrat à durée indéterminée je
parle sous le regard de ceux et celles
qui ont la compétence ici c'est trois
mois de période d'essai s'il s'agit d'un
contrat à durée déterminée c'est un mois
de période d'essai c'est ça le droit
commun qui s'applique en l'occurrence
aux emplois d'avenir comme à tout autre
emploi bien je vais et par conséquent
non madame la présidente de la
commission
j'ai bien entendu l'argumentation de
monsieur le ministre et de monsieur le
rapporteur et j'étais ravi de réentendre
avec force le fait que ce qui est
privilégiée dans ces emplois d'avenir
c'est le cdi et le cdi à temps plein
sauf que hier ici même pour la formation
pendant le temps de travail vous nous
avez
qu'il y aurait des temps partiel
possible et du coup dans le café de
l'exception la loi finalement puisque
dans la loi la formation sera en dehors
du temps de travail
prioritairement pendant le temps
prioritairement pendant le temps de
travail mais mes chers collègues
c'est peut-être pas le lieu d'ouvrir ce
débat ici mais vous savez très bien ce
que veut dire prioritairement pendant le
temps de travail ça veut dire qu'il y
aura aussi des formations et surtout en
dehors du temps de travail donc hier
vous nous faites vous nous dites
l'exception sera le temps partiel
néanmoins dans la loi on dit que le
temps de travail le temps de formation
pourra être en dehors du temps de
travail et aujourd'hui vous nous
réaffirmer avec force et c'est tant
mieux parce que c'est ce que nous
voulons entendre c'est ce que nous
souhaitons effectivement et je crois que
ça vaut pour l'ensemble des membres de
la commission des affaires sociales que
ce sept emplois d'avenir soit
majoritairement mêmes principalement en
cdi et à temps plein donc alors hier on
nous fait l'exception et on nous dit
c'est la loi et du coup aujourd'hui
monsieur le
le ministre vous vous ne voulez pas
entendre que pour ses modulations de
l'aide financière aux entreprises et
bien du coup il faudra aussi prendre en
compte l' exception et je crois que ces
emplois d'avenir sont quand même en
comme cible quand même en priorité ces
jeunes qui sont aujourd'hui sans emploi
donc est-ce qu'on doit privilégier la
situation de ces jeunes qui vont par
sept emplois d'avenir pouvoir remettre
pied dans le monde du travail quel qu'il
soit en collectivité en association ou
par exception dans le services marchands
puisque le service marchand sera
concerné aussi et dans ces cas là si on
veut prioritairement ciblés ces jeunes
là qu'ils sentent en difficulté je crois
qu'il faut aussi prendre en compte leur
leurs préoccupations bien je vous
remercie madame la présidente monsieur
guillaume pour explication de vote
non non monsieur le ministre comment
jeunes apporte quelques éléments dans ce
débat parce que à vous écouter et à
écouter celui qui sait d'expérience
juste auparavant mais ses batteries on a
le sentiment que toutes les associations
les collectivités locales vont se
précipiter et que vraiment elles sont
toutes là immédiatement prête à
accueillir les jeunes en question et que
donc nous nous serions dans une
préoccupation qui consisterait à faire
du chiffre
le plus vite possible c'est qu'elle est
ma préoccupation ce qui est suffisamment
d'associations et de collectivités
locales qui compte tenu du type de
jeunes dont nous parlons soit candidate
c'est ça ma préoccupation première c'est
pas de faire du chiffre 1 c'est qu'on
est malgré tout suffisamment jeudi
malgré tout parce que nous ne sommes pas
dans une entreprise qui chercheraient
simplement avoir un effet d'aubaine
auquel cas je comprendrais tout à fait
qu'on y mette un certain nombre
d'obstacles
nous sommes devant des gens à qui on va
demander de faire un effort en tous les
cas dans un premier temps à qui on va
dire la fois vous mobiliser il va
peut-être falloir que vous me disiez des
salariés pour être aux côtés de ces
jeunes et on voudrait augmenter
augmentez augmenter les obligations il
ya des obligations qui sont nécessaires
qu'il faut mettre en oeuvre nous le
faisons ensemble en termes de formation
en termes de suivi en termes de
formation sur le temps de travail bien
entendu évidemment donc nous avons cette
préoccupation mais moi je vous le dis
très clairement
si on en fait trop il y aura pas de
candidat à l'accueil de ces jeunes et
les jeunes en question auquel nous
sommes tous d'accord pour apporter une
aide
ils resteront là encore une fois encore
à la porte donc c'est cela le problème
c'est ça la difficulté dans laquelle
nous sommes donc prenez le en contre
c'est pas de méchants employeur auquel
nous avons affaire
ce sont des employeurs qui vont devoir
faire un effort qui vont devoir faire un
effort et qui vont pas être si nombreux
que cela vous verrez dans un premier
temps et on aura besoin de vous comme de
tout le monde pour mobiliser les réseaux
pour mobiliser les collectivités locales
pour leur dire c'est l'intérêt général
c'est l'intérêt de la société que de
vous mobiliser
donc voilà la préoccupation qui est la
mienne s'agit pas de faire du chiffre
bon bien bien par conséquent je vais
mettre au voir cet amendement numéro 62
pour lequel la commission et le
gouvernement ont émis un avis
défavorable qui est pour cet amendement
qui s'abstient qui est contre il n'est
pas adopté nous passons maintenant à
l'amendement numéro 71 qui est présentée
par monsieur doublet que présente sur le
vif cet abonnement a pour but d'attirer
l'attention sur le non respect des
engagements de l'employé en matière de
formation peut-être multifactorielle et
non nécessairement imputable à
l'employeur une formation peut être
annulée par un organisme de formation
faute de candidats le salarié peut fuir
refusé ladite formation ou être
indisponible des circonstances
particulières pouvant intervenir il
convient de ne pas pénaliser a priori
l'employeur sans lui donner la
possibilité d'apporter des éléments à
charge de preuve
en conséquence le présente en nommant
vise à permettre à l'employeur de
justifier le non respect éventuelles et
ses engagements en matière de formation
merci monsieur doublet quel est l'avis
de la commission se gêneront oui vous
avez tout à fait raison monsieur double
est l'organisme de formation peut être
défaillant mais il est évident que
l'engagement de l'employeur sera
apprécié de manière globale et il ne me
paraît pas utile d'introduire cette
clause dans le texte qui vous est
proposé c'est pourquoi je proposerai
plutôt un avis défavorable
considérant que par ailleurs le dialogue
qui sera instaurée avec l'employeur
permettra d'aboutir à une appréhension
globale de la situation sans que
l'employeur ne risque d'être sanctionné
pour un défaut de l'organisme de
formation qu'est la vie du gouvernement
même avis
je mets aux voix cet amendement numéro
71 auquel la commission et le
gouvernement est émis un avis
défavorable qui est pour cet amendement
qui est contre qui s'abstient il n'est
pas adopté nous venons à l'amendement 35
rectifiée présentée par monsieur
marseille
mais monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mais chocolate cet amendement
prévoit que le fonds paritaire de
sécurisation des parcours professionnels
assurent une mission d'appui et de
conseil aux employeurs pour la mise en
oeuvre des actions de formations prévues
dans le parcours du bénéficiaire
d'emplois à venir
l'existence d'un tel accompagnement est
un moyen de garantir l'effectivité de la
formation prévue mobiliser les
dispositifs de formation professionnelle
demande une connaissance de ces derniers
une maîtrise des différents canaux de
financement propre à la formation
continue dont ne disposent pas
nécessairement les employeurs qui sont
susceptibles de procéder à une embauche
dans le cadre des emplois à venir
l'accompagnement de l'employeur afin de
sécuriser tout au long du déroulement du
parcours du jeune embauché tout aussi
important pour la réussite du dispositif
que l'accompagnement du jeune lui-même
en particulier lorsque la structure
employeuse peut s'avérer fragile
notamment lorsqu'il s'agit d'une petite
association ou d une activité émergente
merci bien quel est l'avis de la
commission monsieur marseille vous
voulez confié un rôle de conseil aux
fonds de sécurisation des parcours
professionnels
ce n'est pas sa fonction ce n'est qu'un
outil de financement
la fonction de conseil et d'appui est
confiée aux opca
tout cela fait l'objet d'une définition
claire de la part du code du travail
c'est donc un avis défavorable
monsieur le ministre quel est votre avis
mais même il est maintenue jeu
je vais retirer l'amendement monsieur le
président néanmoins là encore il ya un
manque de précision il aurait été bon
dans le texte qui est des précisions
quant au suivi l accompagnement des
jeunes en matière de contrats d'emploi à
venir bien l'amendement numéro 35
rectifier et retiré nous passons
maintenant à l'amendement numéro 59 qui
est présenté par madame pasquet merci
monsieur le président à l'occasion de
l'examen par la commission des affaires
sociales de l'assemblée nationale le
député jean marc germain rapporteur sur
ce projet de loi a posé un principe qui
pour nous est primordial celui de la
stricte conditionnalité des aides
publiques à leur efficacité
nous partageons ce constat qu'il a ainsi
formulé dans la situation financière
difficile que nous connaissons chaque
euro doit être bien dépensée
nous avons d'ailleurs déposé plusieurs
amendements qui nous apparaissent
contribué à cet impératif
or il nous semble que malheureusement si
comme le rappelait monsieur germain en
l'occurrence les effets d'aubaine qui
affecte des aides au secteur privé sont
limitées d'un secteur non lucratif des
mécanismes d'encadrement supplémentaires
pour le secteur marchand doit être
trouvée je note d'ailleurs que
l'amendement adopté à l'assemblée sur la
non attribution de l'aide en cas de
licenciement pour motif économique ne
porte malheureusement que sur le secteur
non marchand 7 certes une disposition
générale interdit déjà le versement des
aides pour le cic yeux si l'entreprise a
procédé à un licenciement pour motif
économique
six mois auparavant mais il aurait sans
doute fallu renforcer le dispositif et
notamment en l'étendant aux plans
sociaux en cours en portant la période
d'interdiction à un an et imprévoyant le
cas de recours massif aux ruptures
conventionnelles
car la réalité que nous connaissons tous
et que dans les grandes entreprises
celles qui bénéficient de conseil en
ressources humaines et en fiscalité
s'organise une véritable course aux
subventions publiques pour profiter le
plus possible de salariés rémunérés à
moindre coût bien que marginale cette
situation existe
et pèsent sur l'emploi de qualité
l'employeur substituant des emplois
durables par des emplois aidés cela
affecte et naturellement la dépense
publique puisque les sommes qui
s'accaparent ne peuvent naturellement
plus être mobilisés pour des secteurs
qui sont plus légitimes que le secteur
marchand en bénéficier ou tout du moins
un enfant une utilisation plus adéquat
nous avons bien compris que les emplois
d'avenir étaient principalement réservé
au secteur non marchand
pour autant le secteur marchand est un
également éligibles dans des proportions
moindres certes il nous semble important
de poser pour ce secteur des règles
spécifiques tel est l'objet de cet
amendement qui propose de ne pas
accorder des aides publiques aux
employeurs du secteur marchand qui
réalisera une forme de cavalerie aux
emplois aidés en faisant en sorte qu à
quand un contrat est déçu depuis succédé
un autre contrat et des chevaux merci
chers collègues
quel est l'avis de la commission sur
janot merci monsieur le président on ne
peut évidemment que partager la
préoccupation de madame pasquet son
amendement vise à éviter une succession
dans pleins d'avenir chez un même
employeur et notamment il vise à éviter
que des employeurs n'abuse de ce
dispositif en jetant si vous permettez
l'expression
les jeunes accueillis à l'issue de leurs
emplois d'avenir mais en même temps tel
qu'il est formulé cet amendement risque
d'empêcher des embauches en emplois
d'avenir pour remplacer un jeune qui
aurait par exemple et c'est l'objet de
deux lampes led à venir trouver un
emploi stable ailleurs donc je vous
propose de plutôt faire confiance en la
matière la vigilance des prescripteurs
du contrat aidé pour repérer les ans les
éventuels abus
j'ajoute que l'amendement suivant mais
qui n'est pas de vue qui n'est pas vu
tout en examen commun l'amendement
suivant présenté par le gouvernement
répond précisément à la préoccupation me
semble-t-il que vous exprimer tout en
maintenant cette possibilité ouverte
pour l'employeur
qui a utilisé est reclassé ailleurs un
jeune en emplois d'avenir d'avoir
recours à nouveau à un emplois d'avenir
pour pouvoir l'accueillir
c'est pourquoi je demanderai à ma
collègue de retirer son amendement ou à
défaut nous émettrons un avis
défavorable en vo demandant votre avis
monsieur le ministre on pourrait mettre
cet amendement en discussion commune
s'ils ne voyaient pas d'inconvénient et
bien allons-y
je connais défendre l'amendement du
gouvernement qui a comme objectif de
répondre en grande partie aux
préoccupations qui ont été exprimées par
les auteurs de l'amendement numéro 59
nous voulons tous pénaliser le mauvais
employeurs qu'ils soient d'ailleurs
secteur marchand ou non marchand lan ou
l'autre et nous voulons au contraire
récompenser celui qui a bien fait son
boulot
or il ya une manière de bien faire son
travail
même si on a assez d'aidé au départ
c'est de faire en sorte que le jeune
soit tellement réinsérer
professionnellement et tellement bien
acquis une formation avec tout ce que ça
lui permet de transférer à bhl c'était
une de vos préoccupations qu'il trouve
un travail ailleurs ou que même il
revient dans le système de formation
donc la formulation de votre amendement
ne fait pas la différence entre le bon
employeur celui qui a permis aux jeunes
de voler de ses propres ailes et le
mauvais celui qui voudrait bénéficier de
contrats les uns après les autres sans
se préoccuper de ce que vient le jeune
donc voilà le risque de l'amendement tel
que vous l'avez écrit au numéro 59
l'amendement tels que le gouvernement
vous en propose la rédaction est un
amendement qui permettra effectivement à
ceux qui seront décisionnaire dans
l'attribution de bien regarder ce qui
est devenu des emplois d'avenir
précédent et d'accorder un emplois
d'avenir à celui qui a bien fait son
boulot est par contre de le refuser
évidemment à celui qui n'aurait comme
seule préoccupation que de voir se
succéder sur un même poste des contrats
à durée déterminée
madame
ce qu'estime et vous votre amendement
satisfait écoutez je pense que
l'amendement du gouvernement
même si il est plus comment dire je vais
plus concentre sur fin espère que c'est
pas le sepa levant mots il n'est pas
c'est pas le même que le nôtre d'une
forme est beaucoup plus exigeant il est
moins exigeant que le nôtre je pense
qu'il va quand même
dans le bon sens et partagent les mêmes
préoccupations que des nôtres donc je
vais me retirer mon amendement au profit
de celui du gouvernement bien donc je
demande quand même l'avis de la
commission sur le 112
monsieur jeannerot l'avis de la
commission sur le 112 je suppose qu'il
est favorable mais j'aimerais vous
l'entendre dit c'est évidemment un avis
favorable au regard des arguments
présentés sur l'amendement précédent
bien donc je vais par conséquent mettre
au vote ou voilà moment 112 présenté par
le gouvernement qui a un avis favorable
de la par la commission qui est pour et
qui est contre
sopo qui s'abstient il est adopté le
passons maintenant à l'amendement numéro
63 qui est présenté par madame cohen
donc monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues depuis le
début d'un autre débat la discussion
montrent que nous sommes nombreux ici a
exprimé la volonté que ces emplois
d'avenir constitue une première marche
vers l'emploi des jeunes en difficulté
c'est d'ailleurs le motif de cette
proposition faite par le gouvernement et
donc nos amendements vont tous dans le
sens d'un enrichissement du texte
apportant les meilleures garanties aux
futurs bénéficiaires dans notre esprit
il s'agit de combattre donc la précarité
en s'adressant à celles et ceux qui ont
déjà connu des stages l'intérim et la
déqualification celles et ceux qui
désespèrent des portes fermées des
petits boulots qui fragmentent leur vie
dans cet esprit nous souhaitons donc que
l'ensemble des droits et avantages
ouvert aux salariés de l'entreprise ou
de l'association ou de l'établissement
public qui les emploient leur soit
ouvert
vous savez certainement comme nous que
il ya un certain nombre d'ailleurs
d'acteurs sur le terrain qui nous ont
fait savoir que par le passé des jeunes
recrutés ans et 8e au ca au s'était vu
privé de certains éléments accessoires à
la rémunération telle par exemple
l'échec
les chèques vacances donc on connaît
bien y compris le profil de ces jeunes
filles ou des garçons qui vont entrer
dans ce dispositif et qui sont éloignés
de l'emploi mais aussi qu'ils
connaissent qu'ils méconnaissent plutôt
les codes des collectifs de travail
qu'ils ou elles vont fréquenter
donc c'est très important de leur
permettre d'avoir les mêmes droits à la
restauration du midi aux chèques
vacances et aux loisirs
et c'est aussi un important levier pour
leur intégration dans le monde du
travail
nous souhaitons toutes et tous donc que
tombe cette méfiance réciproque
en quelque sorte entre l'entreprise et
le jeune et si ce dispositif s'avère
positif il faudra aussi que dans le
bilan il n'y ait pas que des chiffres
que des statistiques mais aussi un
échange d'expériences leur réussite et
peut-être leur échec une politique
publique ne se mesure pas seulement en
termes de statistiques mais aussi à
l'aune du récit de celles et ceux qui
l'ont vécue alors nous savons bien que
c'est lors de l'exercice de ces droits
que des liens se nouent entre les
anciens et les nouveaux
et que les salariés peuvent partager
ainsi l'expérience avec avec leurs
collègues
donc c'est pourquoi nous vous demandons
qu'ils aient accès aux mêmes aux mêmes
droits et
nous nous réaffirmons que s'il y avait
disparités lui aurait une discrimination
au vu du public visé par ce nouveau
dispositif
je pense que ce ne sont pas et vous
serez d'accord avec nous ce ne seront
pas ce ne serait pas les familles qui
pourraient pas lié par exemple à des
dépenses supplémentaires concernant je
les dis la restauration du midi mais
également les transports
donc cet amendement monsieur le ministre
vise à ce que les emplois d'avenir
acquiert tous les droits qui feront
d'eux non seulement des salariés à part
entière mais aussi des citoyens et des
citoyennes dans l'entreprise
merci je vous remercie chers collègues
quel est l'avis de la commission se
gêneront bien eux
merci monsieur le président on ne peut
que partager l'objectif porté par madame
cohen à savoir assurer l'égalité de
traitement entre les jeunes en emplois
d'avenir et les autres salariés
d'ailleurs le législateur ne s'y est pas
trompé puisque par ailleurs ne
l'occasion de voir ce débat en
commission les jeunes admis en emplois
d'avenir pourront être électeur et
éligible aux instances représentatives
du personnel ce qui montre leur statut
égal à celui des autres salariés
c'est donc un avis favorable quel est
l'avis du gouvernement le président je
ferais la même réponse que celui que
celles que j'ai pu faire à d'autres
amendements
le code du travail est applicable aux
emplois d'avenir dans sa totalité
sauf s'il était prévu dans notre texte
qu'il ne le soit pas c'est parce que
nous prévoyons donc tout est applicable
donc les dispositions sont applicables
alors effectivement on pourrait dire ça
a été un peu le raisonnement du
rapporteur puisque le code du travail
est applicable à pas d'inconvénient à ce
qu'on lit m mais dans ce cas là il faut
mettre toutes les dispositions du code
du travail puisque toutes les
dispositions du code du travail
ils sont applicables vous signaler
d'ailleurs madame qu' il y aurait eu des
cas que non vous auriez eu connaissance
ou s'il aurait été refusée à des cae ou
dc e auxquels sont applicables aussi les
dispositions du droit du travail des
refus je vous demanderais d'ailleurs de
me le faire savoir
car ces refus sont illégaux c'est dans
les mêmes conditions il peut y avoir des
conditions d'ancienneté mais ça
s'applique à tous le salarié qui est en
emplois d'avenir comme celui qui n'est
pas en emplois d'avenir mais les règles
sont les mêmes pour tous que les choses
soient très claires
donc du point de vue de la bonne
écriture de la loi c'est la réponse que
j'ai fait à d'autres amendements
je préférerais qu'on ne surcharge pas
cette partie du texte de dispositions
qui existent par ailleurs
mais pour que les choses soient claires
oui toutes les dispositions du code du
travail sont applicables et donc les
rémunérations accessoires avantages
accessoires les emplois d'avenir en
bénéficieront comme tous les autres
salariés de l'association de
l'entreprise ou de la collectivité
locale concernée bien adam cohen
j'apprécie donc la réponse et du
rapporteur de la commission et du
ministre j'ai un doute une question que
je préfère poser dans l'hémicycle je ne
suis pas persuadé qu'un certain nombre
davantage que j'aidais enfin avantage
entre guillemets que j'ai décrit c'est à
dire chaque chèque déjeuner
et des choses concernant les loisirs etc
fasse partie du code du travail si vous
me garantit c'est que ces avantages en
font partie j'ai aucun problème et je ne
veux pas surcharger du tout les choses
mais moi j'avais le sentiment qu'il y
avait un certain nombre d' avantages de
cet ordre là je vais le dire mais je
pense que c'est pas approprié j'allais
dire en nature mais voilà je crois pas
que ce soit très approprié ne faisait
pas partie du code du travail c'est
pourquoi j'avais avec mon groupe
souhaitait ces précisions
maintenant si vous me le certifier je
n'ai pas de problème bien monsieur le
ministre une précision veut dire
clairement les choses donc la loi est la
même pour tous la même pour tous en
l'occurrence pour les salariés après
même dire est ce qu'il ya des
dispositions internes aux entreprises
mais dans les dispositions internes aux
entreprises quand elles disent qu il ne
peut pas y avoir du point de vue du code
du travail de différenciation entre
salariés je le dis ce qui se passe
souvent et c'est peut-être cela qui les
fait référence compte tenu de l'origine
me semble-t-il odeur de vous même et
l'aspiration de cet amendement c'est le
cas des stagiaires puisqu'il ya souvent
des stagiaires dont vous savez combien
ils sont parfois dans des situations
anormales en termes d'exploitation et là
il ya souvent des règlements qui prévoit
que le stagiaire ne bénéficient pas des
mais dès lors qu'on est salarié et ce
sont des salariés en bénéficient des
mêmes droits que les autres salariés
dans l'entreprise dans l'association où
dans la collectivité concernée bien
madame cohen vous retirer votre
amendement
je vous remercie nous passons maintenant
un amendement numéro 64 qui est présenté
par madame parce que
merci monsieur le président une nouvelle
fois monsieur le ministre nous
convoquons la justice et l'égalité qui
doivent nous inspirer lors du débat du
débat de ce texte
il s'agit dans cet amendement de
préciser dans le texte que dont nous
débattons que les jeunes embauchés en
emplois d'avenir puissent bénéficier
d'une priorité d'embauché cas de
création d'emplois dans la structure
d'accueil
nous avons dit au cours de nos
précédentes interventions que nous
partageons votre souci que les jeunes
éloignés de l'emploi puisse bénéficier
de ces emplois d'avenir
nous pensons aussi que méfiance s'est
installée entre du parti de la jeunesse
et l'entreprise mais aussi à l'égard de
celles et ceux qui décident et dont nous
législateurs faisons partie trop de
dispositifs tu les dispositifs une
partie de ces jeunes pensent qu'à
nouveau il ne seront pas dans la bonne
case que ce ne sont que des annonces qui
n'auront pas d'effets sur leur vie
future
les aspire à la stabilité et au cdi ils
voudront bien une nouvelle fois nous
faire confiance
si nous leur disons clairement qu'il
peut y avoir
après les emplois d'avenir nous nous
devons d secré dans la loi cet
amendement car sinon du point de vue de
l'employeur il peut y avoir à but de
l'effet d'aubaine et du point de vue du
jeune il pourrait avoir l'impression que
nous avons créé une nouvelle voie de
garage
elle parking supplémentaires et elle
n'est pas semble-t-il la volonté du
gouvernement et encore moins la nôtre
bien je vous remercie
quelle est la vie
de la commission monsieur gendron cet
amendement 64 bien merci monsieur le
président cet amendement donc propose de
faire bénéficier les jeunes en emplois
d'avenir d'une indemnité de précarité
à l'issue de leur contrat si celui ci
est un cdd
alors évidemment là aussi on ne peut que
partager l'objectif d'une meilleure
indemnisation des jeunes en emplois
d'avenir
néanmoins je pense que ça viendrait
faire peser une charge trop importante
sur l'employeur qui serait en tout cas
dissuasive par rapport à son reste à
charge et nous avons fait un certain
nombre de simulations ça viendra
augmenter dans des proportions
considérables coût de l'emploi d'avenir
pour l'employeur ce qui aurait pour
effet nous semble-t-il de dissuader des
embauches de plus cet amendement
créerait une différenciation de
traitement entre les emplois d'avenir et
les autres contrats aidés pour lesquels
une indemnité de précarité n'est pas
prévu et c'est introduirait donc
là-dessus unis n'est une inégalité de
traitement que rien ne pourrait
justifier c'est donc un avis défavorable
monsieur le ministre donc ce président
basque et présente deux amendements et
64 et puis il y aura le moment de 0 65
qui vient ensuite autant sur le 65 jeudi
par avance je pense que le gouvernement
pourra donner un avis favorable
j'expliquerai pourquoi autant sur celui
ci pour les mêmes raisons qui viennent
d'être avancés par monsieur le
rapporteur
je ne peux donner qu'un avis défavorable
d'abord il l'a dit lui-même laissé coi
cela ils sont beaucoup plus beaucoup
plus beaucoup plus court que ce que nous
prévoyons puisque nous c'est trois ans
est au minimum au minimum un an
et les autres qui sont tous de moins
d'un an la durée moyenne des derniers
qui ont été accordés si généreusement
pendant la première moitié de cette
année pour des raisons qui vous ont
totalement échappé aux uns et aux autres
c'était moins de six mois souvent quatre
mois et dans ces cas là il n'y avait pas
de prime de précarité et là on voudrait
en créer une
il y aurait là vraiment une distorsion
entre une situation qui pourrait être
jugé comme anormale et une situation qui
au contraire cherchent à donner plus de
durée de visibilité pour le jeune et
puis on en a déjà parlé au fond vous à
les pénaliser le plus petit vous disiez
il ya une défiance entre les jeunes et
les employeurs les entreprises je le
répète ceux qui sont en l'occurrence
concernés c'est des associations et des
collectivités locales
c'est le secteur de l'économie sociale
et solidaire
je dis pas qu'ils sont tous
irréprochables même dans les
collectivités locales sont pas tous
irréprochables
enfin malgré tout c'est quand même
pâques globalement le même état d'esprit
que celui qu'on pourrait éventuellement
craindre dans un certain nombre de
secteurs strictement marchand donc
attention à ne pas donner plus à ceux
qui ont déjà beaucoup
les très grands et à pénaliser encore
plus ceux qui ont déjà très peu parce
qu'au bout du compte ce aboutir à quoi
à ce qu'ils ne proposent pas leur
candidature à l'emploi d'un jeune en
emplois d'avenir alors que nous avons
envie de diversifier les possibilités
tout particulièrement dans les zones
rurales par exemple dans les zones
rurales les grands réseaux les grandes
associations sont peu présentes
il peut y avoir de plus petites
associations qui seront prêts à
accueillir et c'est là qu'on va leur
demander de payer plus cher afin de
diminuer considère long de 40 % le
montant de l'aide dont ils pourraient
bénéficier voilà l'état d'esprit dans
lequel nous sommes c'est vraiment parce
que penser à ces jeunes français eux
pensez à eux sur tout le territoire
pensé que ça va pas être si simple que
cela qu'il va falloir vraiment beaucoup
de persuasion pour faire en sorte qu'il
y ait des associations des collectivités
locales aux autres qui soit candidate
pour accueillir ces jeunes et je pense
qu'à partir de cela vous pourrez
partager notre préoccupation données de
la sécurité donner de la formation
donner un avenir effectivement ne pas
les mettre dans des voies de garage
surtout ne pas les mettre dans un
enchaînement de petits boulots et de
galère c'est les sortir de la galère
l'objectif c'est ça les sortir de la
galère dont nous partageons cet objectif
mais faisons attention à ce qu ensuite
ce soit sur le territoire réalisable et
sur tout le territoire français
réalisable merci merci monsieur s il est
maintenu il est retiré
je vous remercie et donc nous passons
aux 65 qui est présentée par monsieur
matin
oui pour de nombreux jeunes qui n'ont
jamais connu d'expérience
professionnelle et dont le niveau de
formation initiale ou de qualification
est faible l'accès aux emplois d'avenir
peut constituer une chance ils peuvent
se révéler en effet ces emplois être un
marchepied condition naturellement que
les jeunes ainsi recruté puissent
bénéficier d'une véritable formation
vient d'en parler dont ils pourront se
prévaloir à l'avenir et ce
particulièrement si à l'échéance du
contrat le jeune recruté ne voit pas son
emploi pérenniser dans la structure
d'accueil
cette question de la pérennisation de
l'emploi est un véritable enjeu pour les
jeunes c'est l'intérêt aussi la société
je crois que nous le comprenons tous ici
nos concitoyens ne comprendraient pas
non plus que les emplois d'avenir n'est
pas d'effet durable est positif sur le
niveau d'emploi des jeunes concernés
donnant l'impression qu'ils n'auraient
été au final qu'un simple traitement
social du chômage
c'est ce constat ceci à notre volonté de
conditionner les aides publiques qui
nous a conduit ce conduit a présenté
différents amendements dont celui ci
alors concrètement il s'agit si aix et
amendements numéro 65 de prévoir à
l'image de ce qui existe d'ailleurs à
peu près pour les licenciements pour
motif économique une priorité d'embauché
pour les bénéficiaires des emplois
d'avenir
aussi nous proposons que le salarié
recruté en emplois d'avenir et dont le
contrat à durée déterminée est échue
puissent bénéficier pendant une période
de un an après ce terme d'une priorité
d'embauché dans la structure d'accueil 6
un emploi et bien évidemment créé bien
je vous remercie cher collègue monsieur
jeannerot pour la commission merci
monsieur le président on ne peut que
partager la préoccupation exprimée par
l'amendement déposé par monsieur watrin
il s'agit vous l'avez compris de donner
une priorité de garantir une priorité
d'embauché pour les jeunes qui ont été
employées en emplois d'avenir à l'instar
de ce qui existe pour les licenciés
économiques sur l'objectif encore une
fois nous ne pouvons que y adhérer nous
nous interrogeons et la commission s'est
interrogé sur les conditions
d'application lité d'une telle mesure
c'est pourquoi j'aimerais sollicité
l'avis du gouvernement sur ce point
monsieur le ministre les a votre avis le
président sur l'injonction du rapporteur
comme la vôtre je voudrais dire que cet
amendement me paraît de qualité et
répondre à une préoccupation c'est quoi
notre objectif c'est le jeune ait pas
d'interruption
j'ai dit contrat à durée indéterminée
bien donc il reste dans l'entreprise
ça peut être un contrat à durée
déterminée qui se transforme ensuite en
une capacité de d'emplois dans
l'entreprise et 9 d'ailleurs c'est comme
ça que ça se passera dans les
collectivités locales sera d'abord un
contrat à durée déterminée puis ensuite
l'accès à un emploi qui sera un emploi
lui-même durable il peut y avoir des cas
où une association ou dans le domaine
économie sociale et solidaire au bout de
trois ans on dise
là je peux pas de garder j'ai pas la
possibilité depuis six mois après on
s'aperçoit que la possibilité existe
c'est à cela que vous cherchez à
répondre et vous avez raison
dans ces cas là comme d'ailleurs dans le
droit du licenciement économique il doit
y avoir une priorité pour celui qui n'a
pas été retenue ou qui a quitté
l'entreprise à occuper un poste
correspondant à celui qu'il a occupé
précédemment et donc monsieur le
rapporteur je veux vous rassurer
puis ce possible ceci est parfaitement
possible juridiquement ce sont des
dispositions dont on connaît
l'application
dans d'autres cas de figure dans les
entreprises ou dans les associations et
donc le gouvernement est favorable à
l'amendement tel qu'il a été présenté
par monsieur watrin mia oui mes
explications de vote de mathieu des
césar oui mais bon je pas avec les
camarades commune et je vais quand même
est en accord mais reprenons le
raisonnement que vous avez monsieur le
ministre
quand vous dites aussi dans six mois un
emploi se libère et les personnes ils
ont envie de reprendre le jeune d'aucune
reprennent à quoi ça sert de mettre dans
la loi
s'ils ont envie de le reprendre le
reprennent donc si on le met dans la loi
ce n'est pas dans le cas que vous venez
de dire c'est dans le cas où ils ont
fait en trois ans un contrat d'avenir
avec un jeune et que ma foi ils ont été
contents du contrat d'avenir mais qu'
ils ont pas obligatoire envie de
reprendre ce jeune là et à ce moment là
l'amendement communiste y retrouve tout
son sens
il oblige l'employeur à reprendre ce
jeune la cdpa dans cas où l'employeur
envie de reprendre le jeune puisque ce
mois c'est pas la peine de mettre dans
la loi
ils veulent faire tout naturellement oui
car quand même le numéro de téléphone
c'est dans le cas où l'employeur
n'aurait pas envie et en l'obligerait
c'est quand même un cas de figure
différentes et donc voila c'était
simplement une observation et je
comprends très bien le souci on va le
voter l'amendement je comprends très
bien le souci mais faut faire toujours
attention et c'est ce que j'ai dit
monsieur le ministre à mettre toujours
des clauses supplémentaires et des
obligations supplémentaires pour
l'employeur et qu'au bout de la dernière
année va se dire si on craint un emploi
on est obligé de prendre ce jeune là
alors qu'il est bien on est content de
ce qu'on a fait mais c'est pas
obligatoire lui convoi pour employés à
durée déterminée donc voilà c'est
monsieur le ministre on est je suis
partagé juste un mot parce que j'aime
bien persuadé jusqu'au bout l'ensemble
des membres de ceux qui sont ici mais
d'autres aussi 6
c'était possible sont des dispositions
qui existent et exactement aussi en cas
de licenciement économique donc votre
raisonnement serait applicable
de quoi s'agit-il d'une obligation
d'information du jeune l'employeur doit
obligatoirement se tourner vers lui s'il
a gardé son numéro de téléphone et lui
dit voilà il ya un poste qui se libère
voilà l'obligation c'est celle là et
j'ai une dernière dernière remarque
monsieur des essarts dernière remarque
j'ai dans mon ministère
une boîte en carton parce que nous
n'avons pas besoin des moyens de nous
payer plus que du carton avec avec une
fente monsieur désessard avec une faute
au milieu une petite fente au milieu de
la boîte en carton en carton recyclable
et à chaque fois que quelqu'un dit
contrat d'avenir c'est 2 euros ce sont
des emplois d'avenir monsieur des
essarts donc vous me dl vous me devez
déjà 4 euros bien nous allons par
conséquent mettre au vote cet amendement
numéro 65 qui bénéficient de deux avis
favorable celui de la commission et les
gouvernements qui est pour cet
amendement qui et contre qui s'abstient
il est adopté
nous passons maintenant à l'amendement 7
rectifié qui est présenté par madame
progression
merci monsieur le président j'ai bien lu
vu que à l'assemblée nationale il y
avait eu de nombreux débats sur les
heures obligatoire ou non à intégrer
dans le contrat d'avenir
j'ai vu aussi vos réponses
j'ai vu vous allez faire fortune au bout
de deux jours de séance monsieur le
ministre mais pour le déficit de l'état
mon avis ça suffira pas c'est bien vu
que vous ne souhaitez plus pas
introduire le nombre d'heures dans le
texte et je suis je vous suis puisque
selon le type de formation selon le type
d'emploi le nombre d'heures n'est pas le
même moi ce que je vous suggère quand
même pour essayer de rendre obligatoire
cette formation c'est d'intégrer dans le
contrat de travail le nombre d'heures
que le jeune devrait suivre en matière
de formation puisque chaque contrat de
travail est adaptée à la personne et
l'art à dire que cette personne peut
avoir deux heures par semaine 10 heures
par mois ou autres permettrait d'avoir
la certitude que le jeune puisse suivre
puisse être formé comme chacun d'entre
nous le souhaite
voilà nous quittons l'hémicycle du sénat
merci de votre fidélité à suivre
l'émission politique de la rédaction de
public sénat preuve par 3 qui reçoit
aujourd'hui le président du groupe
socialiste au sénat françois rebsamen
bonne soirée à tous
on